so I my idea here is to clear the line
of attack and alternate the front foot
but I'm going to start adding to it I
want to have some circularity to my
movement to my angle deviation and to my
body cultivation so that I'm getting
that lateral cross-sectional torque
going on my tissue do you guys
understand that okay and I also want as
I said the whole technique to start
rotating I want to get out of that
two-dimensional grid idea of the world
so when I when I come over here and they
eat your footwork it looks like I'm
going like this it looks like it's just
step out to the side and then the foot
comes across you see that but it's not
it's a rotation my hips my feet are with
my hips and then my hips will rotate and
that's what moves that foot then I never
have the problem of putting myself on a
tightrope where my foot is not under my
hip anymore so when you move out like
this you will almost always get that and
this side of your body never moved off
the line of attack it just moved to the
side of it which is off but you don't
get the rotational torque on the right
side of your body you understand so what
i do is i lock my hips and my legs and
my feet in a relationship and so my
rotation moves my foot do you guys know
i'm not cosmetically stepping there and
then independently moving my foot over
so yes below but there has to be a
torque
[Music]
never what's the difference
this is our body
please start putting more together so
this time you just gotta hang on balance
circle
[Music]
shoulders down let's go don't wait for
and keep it moving
[Music]
don't setup just stick your hand out and
go drop your shoulders get your posture
right be thin breathe out I have to move
that foot maneuver so that his elbow is
gonna get behind and at the point where
I get all that for and all that marriage
with gravity and everything else going
do you understand so I can't just go
forever and go like this and miss him
his elbow has to get behind him where my
weight is then I do my maneuver where
his elbow goes off and over and his
shoulder goes over it's too much around
here get behind him with his elbow hold
that elbow has got to be behind because
you enter behind go for more that's
better
and finder Center what you do it you're
too far out there's some lazy ass you
Kimmy
switch don't setup deviate in turn bull
bull
get it together go
[Music]
find a Center get to strike straighten
your back get your chest out
keep that arch up switch roles lower
lower
too much bend in the arms keep the arch
up on your foot get rid of that iPad
hunch you still got the hunch
breathe in breathe out get the strike up
in his face boom
[Music]
step out we're stepping out now step out
now come on don't intellectualize that
let's go for more
come on
get your footwork hit right Fighting's
closer than that you're too far away
trying to get off of this bridge
mentality okay your reps consider it one
one rep okay so I have already moved
I'm not sitting there waiting for him so
I'm moving towards him
whoa and I'm again knocked away
let's get it done there
[Music]
you're waiting
jail boo inside your outer rim wrong
footwork ground yourself boy are you
going the wrong way
go yours are still of the line of attack
clear the line clear the line clear the
line not move on the line
[Music]
so the hand work is really just won't
quite elbow is turning elbow is turning
not the my arm move okay so I'm here I
put that behind him and my body small
it's his elbow behind him height strike
[Music]
we need your footwork get off the line
your vapor lock English breathe in
breathe out
it's outside your outer rim that elbow
flared turn it over turn it over like
like you did me not get elbow turn the
elbow not the hand
lower base stay low
let's go get the strike in there
inside turn your arm over turn that
elbow up
get your foot to come up get your foot
to come up so your head goes down
[Music]
chest up and out
don't walk to your this side of the dojo
just grab on gotta get your head down
this is the easiest to Kimmy drill I can
give you keep your arch up torque your
elbow arch up back foot arch change
burgers let's go go
someone start
[Applause]
[Music]
inside his arm
keep both sides alive throughout the
technique come in and your 28 should be
able to go forever let's go
help you batting kid yeah
[Music]
come on put it together it doesn't have
to be fast but it has to be together
needs to be a forward roll if it's not a
forward roll it's because you are
jacking it up your fears get in the way
[Music]
right together you know Tammy is now the
neck crowned not after the fact
[Music]